let's go um so many different folks
wanting to chat today let's go next to
glenn from virginia glenn you're on the
air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
just fine
okay great this is my first time calling
thanks for taking the call pleasure uh
my my question for you is with respect
to voting uh rights uh just to give you
context i am an african-american in my
mid-forties
and i fear that uh there will likely be
no meaningful voting rights legislation
uh coming down the pipeline
so my question for you is do you think
the democrats
mischaracterized
well let me rephrase instead of saying
mischaracterize do you think that they
did a poor job in messaging as you know
so much with respect to legislation
comes down to messaging
and what i mean by that is uh with
voting rights legislation do you think
the democrats would have done themselves
more of a service if they sold it as an
issue for the less powerful the less
connected
uh those who are in perhaps
rural areas and having access to voting
as opposed to
selling it more
of a race issue with respect to black
and brown people do you think the
democrats sort of fumbled the football
so to speak in that regard it's always
hard to go back and say what what might
have been but it's a good question which
is if the framing along
uh defending voting rights and pushing
back against all of these wacky
right-wing bills had been
they are going after the little guy
rather than they are targeting
disproportionately non-white minorities
would it have been better received
here's the thing
for the people on the left who
understand the issue
they're already behind supporting voting
rights in a real way and fighting back
against what republicans are doing and
if the left had framed it in the way you
suggest
the right is still going to be just as
against it and they would come up with
some way to justify it and so then it
just becomes a fight of like do they do
it effectively or not i i just don't
know they're sometimes one of the prob
one of the mistakes we make is we say
hey you know what here's the talking
point they came up with and that talking
point was so easily defeated here's a
different talking point that would have
been much better but what you have to
remember is if the talking point had
been different their response also would
have been different and so i just don't
know because fundamentally republican
elected officials know
that they need all of these different
voter suppression tactics in order to
win and they were going to justify them
one way or the other so it's it's hard
for me to say that it would have been
much more successfully
argued if they argued along class rather
than race lines and to be honest
they did also argue it along class lines
because often it's about poor areas not
non-white areas
yeah i i agree uh i just look back at
some of the tactics of uh
you know the obama administration
especially uh in the 2012 campaign
they sort of anticipated the backlash so
to speak and they were much more
nimble
in making the class warfare argument and
even if the republican
attempts are based on
racial uh sensitivities
i just think you do yourself
a lot more uh of a service if you make
the class warfare argument yeah i'm not
disagreeing with you my only caveat
would be i think the republican party
would have been ready for that as well
but i don't think you're wrong
okay fair enough thanks for nicole all
right thanks glenn there's glenn a very
very important topic i mean a great uh
great great uh question to be asking
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video